Today's topic, George Floyd.
So I'm sure most of you have seen the video of George Floyd.
If you haven't go Google it, cuz I'm not gonna watch it again,
nor am I gonna show it on this channel. It is very hard to watch.
There are over 50 million police encounters per year,
and it's sad that people love to raise bait with this, uh,
of even if 500,000 cases where a cop is proven in court of laws
guilty, it's only 1%. Everyone is innocent until proven guilty, even cops,
uh, listen, I don't know what this comment was supposed to mean,
but it was really stupid. And I'll tell you why. It's a stupid idea to have.
There are a lot of cases where cops are woefully competent there at
1% doesn't have to happen. So whether it's 1%, whether it's 2%,
whether it's 10%, doesn't matter to me, you have a job to do.
And if you kill someone on the job,
then you should be held accountable. If it's your own incompetence,
doesn't matter if it's 10%, it doesn't matter.
A man can't go on this family tonight because a cop was INCOM.
That's what it is. You took an oath to protect and serve.
And if you do your job, incompetently suffer the consequences. That's really,
how is that complicated for you? That's pretty simple.
Am I'm in the military and I shoot a civilian.
You think they're gonna let me up? No, they're gonna court martial me.
I will tell you this.
The standard for military people at war with foreign citizens
is way higher than what it is in your own country with police officers.
How does that make any sense? <laugh> how does that make any sense,
bro? I'm so shocked that how incompetent these people are. That's the,
and I'm so shocked that now we're incompetent, but they're not help accountable.
That's so wait a civilian. Can't this up. Can we make one mistake?
We're not even trained to be civilian. No, that's what I'm saying. We.
Don't even know the law. I gotta know how to act with a gun in my face.
They can up with a formation. God, you, with that.
Story time with preach. About a week ago,
I went to fill up my propane tank and there's a police,
his car that went right next to me. And one of the passenger police man,
he said, Hey, what's up preach. And I'm like, Hey, what up man?
Are you everything good? Yeah. It's just that, you know,
I heard that you don't like us. I'm like,
well I'm not the only one that don't like you, but yeah, no,
I'm not a fan of yours. I'm not a fan of your organization. Don't take personal,
you know, it's your organization. Yeah. But you know, we haven't even met.
I'm like, okay know, but we haven't met,
but I've met a lot of your peers and you know,
we don't agree with a lot of things. Right.
And we went on talking and stuff like that and he asked me, how was I doing? Um,
I was that I was good. How was everything? He's like, good.
But it's a bit sad that, you know,
people that we like AB preach say that they don't like us.
You're probably a cool dude. You're probably a cool officer.
And of course it's not all officers, right? It's not,
but where are you when your colleague steps
puts his knees on someone's neck? Where are you?
And what do you say when we get pulled over for nothing?
When your colleagues do it, they do the call.
But you stand there and do nothing. Where are you? See,
it's hard for me to like you, even if you haven't done nothing,
but sometimes that is the problem.
You not doing anything while this happened. And when you watch the video,
you got this man on this, on top of this other man and the other ones,
not doing anything. And that's the problem. They didn't do anything.
When things are getting rough,
they don't do or say anything or hold accountable, their,
their peers, their brothers, because you know, it's a brotherhood.
And that's why they don't say nothing because the brotherhood is strong.
So all those cops that I'm talking to in the street that say, yo, you know,
it's, it's not all of us. Yes.
Somehow some way it's all of you
because when it's time to step up, you don't,
when something wrong happened or your call,
he has a bad day and takes it out on a citizen. You don't say nothing.
You let it happen because the brotherhood is too strong.
So yeah, I'm say it's all of you. It's all of you. If you're not with us,
because you're supposed to serve and protect, you did a oath on this.
When you started working. If you don't go on that, then it's all of you,
all of you, you didn't pull the trigger. It was your knee.
But by you not doing anything and not saying anything and by keeping on saying
that, oh, well, you know, we don't have the evidence and it's too.
And I wasn't there. You're part of that. The brotherhood. So yeah.
I'm gonna say this. There are good cops out there,
but it's all of you because all of you the up when it's time to.
Talk. All right. The guy who asked the previous question about 1% is back again.
Know there are always bad cops of all races,
but the media loves to paint it as black and white.
Everyone makes a mistake at work and cops have less than a second to make split.
Split.
Second decisions on purpose is one thing you guys should do a right along, bro.
I'm tired of people acting like what police officers have to do is the most
stressful job in the world. Calm the down.
You guys have tremendous amount of powers.
That means that you have tremendous amount of responsibility.
That's the way it works. And.
Who put you there? Was it a, was it, did you have, was it a pole?
Did you have to take it out of the hat? What did you shoot?
What did you get today? Oh, I got janitor. What did you get? I got cop. No,
you chose the.
Job. You chose the job.
There you go. So you have to know exactly. It's like, you know,
it's very difficult to be a, it's very difficult to be a teacher concur,
but I didn't study in that. You did. You went there. You have to.
If you are willing.
To take the job, you're willing to take the risk.
You're willing to take the accountability. If you up. You're accountable, bro.
I can't get away with the boxy in public. As a member out of uniform,
these guys are in uniform,
murdering people on camera with not even policy
sanctioned, strangle holds.
And you want me to believe it's okay for them to get off SCO free, man.
outta you. I don't care how many split second decisions.
If you're not good for the job, stay the out the kitchen.
And Jo Lee Reyer rights. I work in nursing.
If a patient died on my shift by my negligence,
by not showing my due diligence or I knew a nurse was not in the right care,
I could still be fired. Absolutely. Meaning if a nurse sees another nurse up,
she gets fired. And if she doesn't say, she's done.
I know we had a business in that business.
That's why a lot of military members do not respect a lot of law enforcement.
No, it's like your training is trans. Well you're rent.
You guys don't know the rules and regulation like bro.
I would be so afraid of getting court martialed that I would make sure I acted
right.
Cuz the idea of being sent to a military prison and they will do it is scary to
me. They make sure, you know the consequences. When you up,
they punish you thoroughly and they punish everyone around you who saw you
up and did nothing. So you know,
there's one cool thing that I loved about the military.
I'm gonna give you guys those side story. When I remember doing base training,
uh, what would they would do?
And this is probably the most creative form of punishment that you guys can use
on your kids. If you have multiple children, <laugh> if I would up.
If I I'm, I'm not even joking. If I would up royally,
what they would do is it would make everyone around me, started doing pushups.
They would make them sit in pushup position.
They would make them do all kinds of punishments.
While I sat there and watched you want a glass of water? Huh? Are you good?
Five? You want, are you good? Do you want a pillow?
Let's get you fix that's right. Let's get you a pillow. That's right.
Your that's right. Let's you are you cool?
And if you have any idea how terrible you felt, cause you,
it is one of the most crushing things to know that your up affected everyone
around. Everybody's going to have to talk with you.
And that's how we talk about when we say accountability,
it's not a one person thing. It's everyone.
That's what I loved about it is the idea that you guys are all in this together
and you're all account to other that matters.
And that's why when I see other military personnel,
I traditionally respect them. Absolutely.
Unless they're fat outta shape that I'm like, get the outta here.
But otherwise I respect it because I know that you've been through the same.
You don't get to pass basic. Generally, if you're completely docx,
it still happens sometimes.
But most of the times you have to have least been decent.
If you guys aren't aware, I saw this interesting post from John Jones,
what he said as a jujitsu expert,
the stranglehold that they put on that man is a form of
yes. Right? They didn't just cut the oxygen to his lungs.
They also cut the blood flow to his brains. And so all this idea of like, well,
how can he talk if he's that doesn't mean that you're not suffering.
And that doesn't mean that you're not struggling.
If you can talk while someone's choking you, it's not because
you're not being choked. It's just a reality of that experience.
A of people can talk while they're being show doesn't mean that they're not on
the brink of death,
but what they did to this man is so incredibly painful that most
jujitsu experts would never practice that on someone else.
That's how dangerous it is. They did that for six minutes.
They put just enough pressure on his net where he could barely get somewhere
it's out, but could it really fully oxygenate his blood or his brain bro?
To me, I couldn't watch that.
It was that disturbing for me right along is a good idea with senior cop.
I'm a past military and law enforcement.
They do terminate people for purposely messing up.
Well clearly in law enforcement, they don't do it enough.
Don't know what to tell you, bro. Don't know what to tell you.
But these are my assessments.
The idea that you can be fired for incompetence from the cop in one jurisdiction
and then be hired in another jurisdiction that's done. That's ridiculous to,
and there's people that live in the borders. It's like, oh I got fired there.
Shoot. Yeah. Oh, let me just go. Let me cross the date. Let me cross the, my,
to me rice, the cop, I believe who murdered him. <affirmative> right.
He's from a different district.
He got fired or let go for incompetence or some other problem there.
And he ended up in the next one and guess what?
He turned out to still be incompetent.
I don't know if police brutality has gotten worse,
but I do know it's getting filmed. That's what I know.
I do know its gotten filmed. That's what's scary. Imagine back then. What,
how it was? Well,
I know from my personal experience before all these cameras were around that my
interactions with officers were not pretty, I know same, same, you know,
what's up bro is I didn't even know about this stuff before I immigrated back
here.
Like I remember coming back here when I was 15 and a lot of these ideas of race
and problems with police didn't really register in my mind, not at all.
Hmm.
And I remember my first police incident where there was this girl being
surrounded by dudes and then me and my friend helped her get away from those
dudes cuz they were gonna, you know, her mm-hmm <affirmative> and uh,
she was kind of screaming out.
So we helped her out and the three guys ended up running off afterwards.
We helped her out. She started like, are you like you? Okay?
Do you need us to call your cab? Blah, blah, blah. She's like, no, I'm fine.
I'm gonna walk home. I don't live far from here. So she ended up walking on.
We were waiting for the bus stop. It was new year's Eve.
I think it was like 2000. Right? You told me that
2008 mm-hmm so I was around 18 and last bus.
We wanted to catch it freezing rain. I'll never forget that night.
Cops just pull out of nowhere. Talk about 6, 7, 8 cop cars,
everyone running around, like it's a SWAT thing.
Apparently there was a camera set up and they'd seen on the camera and someone
called the cops, cops run up at us, guns drawn, put your hands up off,
blow your brains down. I was like, what are you talking about? But I was like,
I was confused. Yeah. They, they in movies, sometimes this guy screaming,
screaming, doing all this crazy. I'm like, bro, what is happening right now?
Right? So I complied all this.
Man goes through all this trouble trying to accuse me saying,
we saw you on camera. You try to reap that girl. I was like, what the? I,
I helped her. What are you? What are you talking about?
Minutes go by. And this person realizes that they up.
You would think they would apologize. He's no, this guy looked at me. He's like,
let me see your bus pass, dude. Rips it up. He makes me miss my last bus pass.
I'm five, six hours away. I have no way of calling my parents.
I remember having to walk.
I remember having to walk in freezing rain angry cuz you know when
you're not guilt of something and you get accused that anger that you feel is
uncontrollable. I wanted to punch things.
I wanted to break things on people's heads. I remember just being so,
so angry cuz I know I didn't do anything.
I know myself to be a decent person and this person treated me like garbage and
I can't do nothing about it. That frustration, that anger that I feel,
I can't let go of that. And so it stays in me. Right?
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and when you have continuous experiences like that over
time and everyone says, just comply,
just comply guys in the mind, if you comply,
nothing will happen to you. Well,
the reality is I'm human and the reality is after a while,
sometimes it gets to be too much.
I want to go about my day undisturbed and you keep,
keep, keep coming after me and bother me about some.
I'm riding a bicycle on my way home.
And you pull up next to me and ask me if I'm getting in trouble and you want to
shake me down and search me.
Why do you have the right to touch me without any probable?
Cause what the is this? Why do I have to be molested by strangers?
So then you tell me afterwards when I finally get mad. Oh yeah.
Well it's your fault that the cop killed you because you should have kept your
cool. Sometimes it just gets to be too much.
All of us humans have a boiling point. So the bad, the best, the best, um,
example that I give to people. When I understand,
I wanna try to tell them is like, okay, so you want me to comply?
You want me to keep my all right, cool. Let's let's read a little experience.
Your Abba. How you doing? You? Good. I'm good. You good? How are you?
I'm good. Alright. I'm good. Cool. Uh, you sure you good naked?
You know you are you, he said it twice and I'm already annoyed.
That's the third time. And I'm just asking him if he's good.
The fact that the police officers were fired, doesn't solve anything either.
That's not what we want to see that they're fired. That's not okay.
You took some problematic officers, right? They need to be charged.
Now something thing needs to happen. Other than that, no,
I don't have any under take I'm I'm a bit tired of talking about like that.
I'll be honest with you guys.
Initially. I didn't wanna cover this.
I've I've told you guys we've covered so many of these stories.
It gets very difficult to watch this stuff like that.
I know. I don't always know what I'm gonna add to a conversation.
What more can I say from the last 10 times this incident happened?
What more can I say? That's gonna sway the conversation in a way.
Most people know this stuff happens. They understand it's a reality. Okay.
Maybe change takes time. Maybe. I don't know why. Maybe I'm impatient.
I don't know. I don't know. But I see this so often. I'm like,
what can I say more than the last 20
videos we did on the stop and.
People have been flooding our DMS. I hope you going talk about this.
I only talk, you hope you gonna talk about that. Oh,
when you sent that to our DM
in this new case that happens in front, what is different than the last.
One? The last 20? Sometimes we just,
we have nothing to add because the truth is
we've done covered this.
I don't have any you insight to do so maybe I'm just making this video so that
you guys who are feeling some type of way and have this flood of emotion,
I understand. Want to get in these comments. And basically,
but we've said this a hundred times.
We know what those guys did, what those police officers did was murder.
You know why? You know why that's not a question.
Um, I was not trying to get your insight on there. I was really just a,
you know why you did that? You know what they did, that's it,
that's it on top of that. I'm gonna wait till this unfolds,
but there's more evidence of him not even resisting arrest.
So it's even more my buddy, I'm gonna say this. All right, right now,
like you're black man. And you live in America and you haven't been, uh,
to jail. You don't have a gun and you don't film yourself all the time.
I'm gonna call it irresponsible.
Wait, wait, are you advocating that, that person,
what fires his gun at the police?
Well, the police is not there to save him, but.
You know, he's gonna go to jail for life. So what is your, what are,
what are you saying? You know what.
I'm saying? I don't have.
A solution. Fair say that,
but don't say get a gun as if it's gonna save people from this situation,
because we've seen what happens when black people have guns. Yeah. True.
Having a gun would not have stopped the situation in any way, shape or form.
In fact it probably would've made it worse. Definitely.
Cause it would've felt more threatened. Yeah.
Even if it's a legal firearm and everyone's protecting their second amendment,
we.
Had a gun. Now you have a reason. The gun would be a reason. Yo. Yeah. I don't.
You know what? Yeah. I don't know. I don't know.